the mta here in new york which is uh the
mass transit authority
they had to officially ban [ __ ] in
the subways
and robbing a train in the train okay
not at this in the train i just wonder
how they're gonna catch the culprits
that's
all i'm saying the worst [ __ ] story
i ever heard on the subway
richard christie who is gross to begin
with he
was on the subway and it was empty and
he's from kansas he didn't know what was
going on and he was like oh my god an
empty car this is great and he took
a seat and he sat down in a big pile of
[ __ ]
like he zeroed right he said squared
down on this
did he miss it well most people if you
sat in some
homeless guys [ __ ] you'd go home richard
then
was on his way to a bar and his [ __ ] all
over
at the outside of his pants and he goes
to the bar and he spent the night there
it was like a two-hour trip to the the
heart of brooklyn from the upper west
side and i was
i was halfway like through my trip and i
wasn't paying attention
people are like waving their hands at me
like don't sit down don't sit down
what are the odds that you even found
the [ __ ] on the chair
i mean you know what i mean like you
could have sat down and it would have
been bad just to smell it but
yeah and it wasn't just a turd it was
like a loose
stone i'm gonna throw up oh sorry robin
but i should have known because
everybody like it was the only
seat available on the subway and i was
like oh look i'm my lucky day i got a
seat but but aren't you scaved out
there's
a human [ __ ] all over you don't know i
mean it's probably a sick person i mean
is drinking that important to you to go
to a hey well it is
yeah yeah what are you asking
[Laughter]
heard you fell down on the street and
you wrecked your hand
what you know are you drinking no i was
running
oh look at that did you break it it's
i think so i mean everybody aren't you
in pain you haven't gone anywhere
to have it looked at no i'm gonna see
how bad it gets it's all kind of gooey
today
and i think you can go now yeah cause
it's
my stomach's queasy too for the last day
or so
yeah man you're pretty [ __ ] macho
that finger thanks
no not really yeah it's probably broken
oh god can i tell you something real
quick
okay i'm gonna be a dad again i
i was afraid he was gonna say that
keep that to yourself congratulations
richard thank you robin
you mean the guy who made the decision
to sit in [ __ ]
and wear it to a bar is gonna be
somebody's father again
oh yeah how's bobby gonna take this
howard
well you hear bubby in the background
you would think like you know bubby's a
tough kid you know bobby
cries a lot and screams and has to get
his way no that was like
he that day was something that was tough
different because both his parents were
not like
paying attention to him well what's
gonna happen when you have a new baby
and you can't pay attention to bubby
well i'll be on bubbe duty and
my wife will be on new baby duty and
you'll be sitting in duty
i'll be sitting in duty there'll be a
lot of duty going on